well it's the second week in November
which means Halloween has come and gone
but there's still pumpkins lying in the
fields and that's why I'm here in Encino
at the Tapia brothers farm to help them
get rid of some of these time to die
that's broken
let's some more pumpkins
I never sworn amazed before
your tips to the Hollywood for my
aggression well you know what this is
really better for gathering
oh you want a pumpkin it's not still
baseball season
[Music]
got it and now a scene from the 1987
film The Untouchables and thews II
Azam's one of mine what draws my
admiration what is that which gives me
joy baseball
[Music]
all right now this is more like it this
is a exploding tip arrow that you can
only get if you're on a cable talk show
in the hole as they say
that's fun I recommend that okay well
next we decided that we would use a
pumpkin chucker
we've turned it into a shooting gallery
for a collection of some of the world's
biggest monsters that's actually
supposed to be Charles Manson there on
the left and then we've got Dracula
we've got venture capitalists creep
Martin shkreli and John from Sports
Authority who's a real dick to me last
Wednesday
[Applause]
a job do you think maybe - here - not
too busy to help me now
[Applause]
[Music]
while we had the pumpkin chucker we
thought it'd also be fun to try it on a
moving target so we drew straws and I
lost
[Applause]
alright enough screwing around let's
just blow up some pumpkins
well once again I've provided a valuable
service for the American small farmer
we've cleared away a lot of old
inventory for these guys although we do
have a pretty big pile of some pretty
big pumpkins left I think we better drop
a car on them
[Applause]
sword
[Applause]
I've never seen our crew happier than
when they were throwing pumpkins that
yeah hey thanks for watching please
subscribe to my youtube channel so they
will stop making me shoot these videos
please